ja ich grüße herzlich christian füller
freier journalist hefner ist die wende
ist der neustart des union wahlkampfes
gelungen am wochenende
stellt man sich so eine wende und einen
guten auftakt den jetzt weiß nicht
dritten gefühlten der cdu der union in
den wahlkampf vor dass die spd dann am
montag sozusagen in allen zeitungen
einen riesigen rückstand gegen die union
aufgeholt hat nein das war sicherlich
keine wende es war dass
herr laschet und zusammen mit markus
söder und angela merkel aufgetreten sind
markus söder vor allen dingen hat seine
zeit reichlich ausgenutzt nicht um über
armin laschet zu reden also das war kein
starker wahlkampfauftakt was zurückblieb
von diesem wochenende war ein
versprecher das ist ein bisschen unfair
dass armin laschet gesagt hat die gsg 9
hätte in landshut
menschen gerettet das war aber in der
lufthansa maschine landshut in
mogadischu so etwas verbreitet sich das
ist das ergebnis dieses wochenendes das
ist nicht gut welchen anteil hat markus
söder sie haben eben schon erwähnt mit
einer recht langen redezeit an diesen
schlechten werten die die union hat man
hat so ein bisschen den eindruck markus
söder könnte momentan oder ist momentan
ein ziemlich guter wahlkämpfer für die
spd und olaf scholz
ja das stimmt markus söder hat durch so
einen ringkampf mit lasche den er ja
nicht so richtig doll verloren hat
ehrlich gesagt dass die union sich dann
dass die cdu sich für ihren vorsitzenden
ausspricht war eigentlich klar aber er
hat dazu beigetragen
andererseits hat es natürlich auch damit
zu tun dass einfach auch unter den
kollegen und kolleginnen
armin laschet einfach keinen starken
eindruck hinterlässt das muss man sagen
er hat keine starken momente in diesem
wahlkampf er hat wenig starke argumente
inhaltlicher art wir haben jetzt diese
diese redepassage gesehen da kann man
sich ja fragen was hat er eigentlich
gesagt also das kann man glaube ich
nicht nur söder zu rechnen das hat damit
zu tun dass
wir einen einen wahlkampf der
kleinigkeiten haben der einen seite auf
der anderen seite haben wir riesige
herausforderungen jahrhundert bewegungen
die da sind die pandemie
der zusammenbruch eines 20-jährigen
kriegseinsatzes in afghanistan also das
sind eigentlich und das klima das sind
eigentlich riesen themen die aber nicht
so richtig von den dreien vielleicht
noch am meisten von annalena baerbock
behandelt werden aus afghanistan kommen
wir gleich auch noch zu sprechen sie
haben es eben auch gesagt die spd und
die union sind erstmals gleichauf bei
rund 22 fünf wochen vor der
bundestagswahl liegt das nur an der
schwäche der union
also ich sage mal so es wird jetzt noch
viel zeit sein auch wenn dir insgesamt
sozusagen nur noch vier wochen sind aber
es ist genug zeit um sozusagen die
fehler die olaf scholz früher gemacht
hat noch auszuleuchten ich sehe im
moment nicht dass olaf scholz irgendwie
kämpferischen nach vorne geht er ist
wirklich jemand der sich jetzt
zurückhält und guckt dass die umfragen
langsam auf ihn zulaufen das ist ein
bisschen verwunderlich aber es hat
sicherlich mit der schwäche der anderen
beiden parteien und vor allem der
anderen beiden kandidaten kandidatinnen
zu tun und natürlich hat olaf scholz
einen vorteil er ist der finanzminister
er kann in die flutgebiete fahren und
kann milliarden versprechen das ist
natürlich ein großer vorteil für ihn
aber man soll sich jetzt nicht blenden
lassen die hohen persönlichen
umfragewerte für olaf scholz
werden die wahl nicht entscheiden am
ende ist es ja entscheidend welche
partei vorne ist und dann haben wir ein
sechs parteien system in dem keiner echt
die nase vorne hat das wird sehr
komplizierte verhandlungen geben wir
haben noch einen kurzen moment für eine
kurze antwort afghanistan wird
sicherlich ein wahlkampfthema bleiben
die aufarbeitung der evakuierung aber
natürlich auch dann die debatte über
geflüchtete das ist ja ein thema vor dem
viele politiker angst haben wie könnte
man damit jetzt konstruktiv umgehen
ja man muss diese debatte natürlich
führen in diese debatte hat uns das muss
man ganz klar sagen die regierung mit
ihren wichtigsten ministern in den außen
und verteidigung gestürzt es war
vollkommen klar dass wenn man aus
afghanistan abzieht dass man dann
natürlich die hilfskräfte in schutz
bringen muss das ist nicht organisiert
worden das ist ganz schlecht organisiert
worden wir schauen täglich auf ein chaos
in kabul jetzt werden sogar angeblich
deutsche hubschrauber eingesetzt um
sozusagen im feindesland leute zu retten
also das muss aufgearbeitet werden und
wir müssen auch dann natürlich darüber
reden annalena baerbock hatte angetönt
dass wir natürlich viel mehr als nur die
nächsten angehörigen der arbeitskräfte
retten müssen sondern möglicherweise
mehr da ist armin laschet ein schritt
voran gegangen indem er ein kontingent
von 1000 frauen die ihr aufnehmen will
in nordrhein westfalen ist er
vorangegangen das ist vielleicht ein
richtiger schritt wir müssen dieses zum
thema machen sagt christian füller
freier journalist ich danke herzlich für
dieses gespräch
danke